joining me now Ned Ryan CEO of American
majority Ned this is tricky for the
Democrats is it not because
they they push Biden out over the over
the
objections clearly of his wife who's
desperate to stay in the white house but
they push him out and they're left with
the woman who Giggles nervously when she
talks about you know outer space so
where do they go from that
well I think there's a Twist to this
plot sure I mean Biden's going to be 82
it's going to feel like 102. it feels
like 102 some days already
but if Biden doesn't want to leave it's
going to be very hard to push him out if
he wants to run for reelection it's
going to be very hard to to beat him in
in the 2024 primary and Laura I'd point
to the 1980 Primary in which you had
Jimmy Carter who was deeply unpopular
not doing well in the polls was
considered very weak was careening from
disaster to disaster and Ted Kennedy ran
against him and Jimmy Carter crushed Ted
Kennedy and I think that's what people
are looking at right now and realizing
Biden is going to have to leave of his
own volition and if not I don't see
anybody that's going to actually a
credible Canada that's going to run
against him uh in the 2024 primary and
if he decides not to run then you get to
Kamala Harris and we know why she was
chosen they needed to find somebody who
was less intelligent than an impaired
Biden and she has done that very well or
do you have a little Pete do you have
Gavin Newsom I mean you're left with a
pretty short bench for Democrats if
Biden doesn't run again and then you
also abandoned Biden's power of
incumbency they've kind of put
themselves into a pretty tough corner
yeah I now I get your point um by the
way CNN in a move which is kind of has
to has to make the North Korean
spokesman for Kim Jong-un kind of
jealous because there was awesome
propaganda coming out of CNN today about
Biden's physical
we got Memo from the president's
physician related to that visit to
Walter Reed those results say President
Biden remains quote healthy and vigorous
It also says that he is fit to
successfully execute the duties of the
presidency so a good news report for the
president there's no signs that would be
anything other than that
Ned I mean I I don't know how a reporter
can even read that with a straight face
I mean did anyone see Biden today when
he uh when he stumbled back to the
microphone when you got a bit of a tough
question about his family's talking to
China I mean I'm sorry but it looks like
Tales from the Crypt it's terrifying I
it's just it
it is it's again it's it's don't believe
Your Lying Eyes in which you see it
let's let's face it a very decrepit
80-something year old who is in the
White House and and I have to tell you
Laura I I don't see him actually doing
most of the governing uh even though he
is the president of the White House and
and we're told to actually believe that
this guy is fit and ready to run again
and I but but again I'll go back to if
if there's not a rapid mental decline
over the next six to nine months and he
decides he's actually running I just
don't see any credible candidate
stepping up to challenge him much less
beat him in the 2024 primary
hey Ned um before we let you go what do
you think of Giselle fetterman
who pushed this poor man to run for
Senate now he ends up in the hospital
with clinical depression after already
being hospitalized I mean is there a
more Twisted scenario than this frankly
cruel scenario than this it feels very
much like a Lady Macbeth situation which
she's very ambitious and she used her
impaired husband as the vehicle to
achieve some of her ambitions
it's it's sickening I mean it's
sickening and cruel um Ned great to see
you thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else